king yep stepping across and plus 100  means checkmate is coming  no way to prevent it there's just one  trick left with white's g-pawn pushes  that can sacrifice the bishop so white's  bishop goes away  no more stalemates and pregnant  is he about to resign he  i think he's giving up and then his  chances have gone  david anton really nice end game  technique we've got to give credit to  the spaniard  that's in a few seconds we will see a  result  this is almost a little bit  heartbreaking he was one win away from  qualifying to the knockout stage in the  air things masters  pragnanda  and now  now it's going to be basically down to  tie breaks knocking him out of this  tournament  after such an incredible performance and  look at that hundred on the bar and it's  over david anton makes it through to the  quarter-finals  it ends here for  after such an incredible perform